crazy computation lifting for PvP and
once is around hello everybody so my
co-authors are the usual suspects for me
Tony and Tom so suppose this is relevant
to the workshop because we are using
some pseudo randomness limits and
properties in the proof so you can start
holding your breath it will appear later
on but on a more higher level what this
talk is about is about relating query
and communication complexities for a
large glass of boolean functions so we
study both query complexity this
decision trees and communication
complexity communication protocols and I
suppose for the two mathematicians in
the audience I'm to recall what a
decision tree is its model to evaluate a
boolean function so f is a boolean
function takes n bits spits out one bit
and it evaluated by repeatedly queering
individual input bits of the input until
finally knows enough about the input to
to output a value at a leaf of the tree
the complexity measure is the height of
the tree which is the number of queries
here you're making on the other half we
have a communication protocols that are
a lot more powerful model of computation
again you're revising boolean function I
call it capital left because now the
function comes with a by partition of
its input bits into two parts and Alice
part x and a bob or twine and instead of
creating individual input bits you can
evaluate whole arbitrate predicates
serve either the left side of the alley
side of the input of the Bob side of the
input so of course we visualize these
rallies and Bob holding their inputs and
they're having a discussion sending bits
to each other so the cost here is again
the height of the protocol tree which is
the number of bits that are communicated
and of course these protocols are much
more powerful than decision trees mean
if you have a decision tree for some
function you can convert it to a
protocol of equal cost by just
simulating an individual query by having
the player that holds a bit communicate
that value to the other
and the strict neural policies to come
up with functions that have low
communication completely but large query
complexity so the theme of this line of
work that I'm going to talk about is to
find general situations in which you
could show that these two models are
actually equally powerful so a large
class of functions where this would
happen this would be really nice for
applications because you could analyze
communication protocols but just
analyzing this simple things decision
trees so they'll be considering this
large class of function called composed
functions so it starts out by just take
your favorite boolean function on n
input bits so these you starting created
complexity and then you turn it into a
communication problem by composing it
with a small to party function we call
these gadgets so it takes some bits from
Ali's some bit from Bob and produces one
bit which is then fed to the the outer
function f so many functions in
communication complexities Jonas the
most important function in this field
it's of this form it's a big or a bunch
of little and gate so take one bit from
each player so more generally you could
consider then having this gadget be
slightly a more complicated function
maybe it takes em bits from both players
produces one bit for the outer function
so alice is input then would be this MN
a bit binary string so it's like you
have a n blocks each of length n and the
intention here is that if you choose
this gadget as a complicated enough
gadget then the compostable should be
hard to compute for protocols because
you don't know what the inputs to the
outer function are before you
communicate enough information about the
particular gadget so if you want to know
one of the inputs that you need to
communicate stuff about the inputs of
that candidates so it's like you have to
communicate bits to create an input to
the outer function so that's the
intuition why we generally conjecture
that for our check carefully chosen
gadget and for any outer function the
query and communication complexity
should be related so call this is a
lifting theorem template
you can instantiate this sort of a claim
for any type of computation you desire
so I am here is a placeholder for it's a
deterministic or non deterministic model
which you can then further instantiate
frybo query or communication complexity
so I expect this to hold whenever you
choose the gadget complicated to be a
complicated enough one and well okay
that a bunch of papers that have proved
these sorts of theorems there's one for
for deterministic thing that holds non
deterministic many models that are
created complexity characterized in
terms of polynomials you can many such
models you can consider the exact degree
the approximate degree or threshold
degree or so forth but still this is one
type of computation that's conspicuously
missing which is randomized models and
so that's that's what we're doing in
this work I suppose this was conjectured
a bunch of other people so it's been
really in the air so what would we show
is that if you choose for your gadget
this index gadget so here alice is
holding this pointer number from 1 up to
n and bob is holding a string of nvm
beads the index together is just looking
up it Bob string the X bit so our result
main result is that if you choose this
some polynomial sized index gadget maybe
the constant on to fight optimist but
sir emma is a polynomial n then we do
get this characterization for the
communication randomized communication
complexity the complex function maybe i
should say that here Bob's input does
blow up polynomially but Alice is still
holding these login bit pointers any of
them so letís input doesn't blow up too
much well nevertheless maybe the input
size blows out but but this is going to
be interesting scale of things happening
the complexity is characterized by the
complexity right so one so I was
inspired by this this talk last week we
had this journalist in residence talked
about history the Silicon Valley and
technological development and their
societal impacts so that got me thinking
what are the societal impacts of a
theorem like this I figured it out so so
this kind of a thing it puts people like
me out of a job because it automates the
task of pretty lower bound so I'm no
longer can I write these kind of long
technical looking papers that separate
two models in a in an ad hoc fashion and
we've certainly done this a lot but now
they kind of follow as a black box away
from this if you want to separate
something from randomized communication
so just to spell this out for them if
you have some some separation in query
complexity against again some
placeholder measure large randomized
query kopecks it was low whatever you're
interested in then you can just compose
you're witnessing function that exhibits
a gap with the indexing function and you
get quantitatively like up to log
factors similar cap for communication so
here just on the left hand side that's
just saying that these two quantities
are related by logarithm mats are a
theorem the right hand side you it's
always true that probable can simulate a
decision tree just a trivial direction
so maybe you can imagine that now we can
just go a ham and derive all sorts of
new applications but it turns out that a
no for the interesting reason that for
any conceivable application of this
previously we have already went ahead
and prove these things in an ad hoc
fashion so at the moment i can't say
that anything any new interesting
application would follow but we do get
simplified and unified proofs for
previous results so here's something of
something that we and other people have
been doing recently like separating
classical from one tomb
in the communication world so we had
this fox paper for example that proved a
super quadratic gap for a total function
between classical and quantum
communication complexities kind of a
horrible mess but but it was modeled on
top of a previous query complexity
separation so then now also just follows
directly from the query separation with
not ad hoc stop making mentions this is
an interesting projector in query
complexity about a particular concrete
function then this is studied by
arrington and a minus some
generalization of the four elation
function which if you could prove
randomized to a lower bounds for it it
would improve this gap from 2.5 to 3 in
query complexity and therefore by this
mutation theorem also for communication
complexity in an ad hoc fashion in a
direct fashion whereas previous methods
they don't imply it in a black first
look black box fashion so at least s
about kind of a push that potential
future application there okay we can
also do some exponential separations for
partial functions and so forth okay so
let's um let's maybe see a little bit
about how this lifting 0 is proved
what's the non-trivial part there exists
is as an equality but the lower bound is
the interesting part but depending on
how you view is the lower about on
communication or an upper bound on
rewritten XD and that's it's not even a
huge job this because you can phrase the
Spruce in two different ways that's why
we call this either lifting theorem so
simulation theorems lifting is saying
the some maybe certificate of hardness
in the query world you can make me
construct a certificate of hardness
communication world many lifting
theorems work like this but I do prefer
this more algorithmic way of thinking
about it of starting with a protocol and
convert it into a decision tree of EP
equal learn Alexa t two smaller
algorithmic but of course he suggests
we're just talking about the same thing
in a different language so i think my
first point i want to make is that what
to reformulate this main theorem
to kind of focus on what's essential so
I argued if it's not essential this
holds for all F so somehow the theorem
is really about the gadgets not about in
fact it would hold even if i put it's
still a vest a search problem or
something more general so let's let's
reformulate this problem so here's the
the communication matrix of the compose
function so alice is given again n
copies of a pointer and bob has n tables
is to each of em bits so this is the
input domain of this problem and so the
first thing we do is we imagine
partitioning the communication matrix
into these what we call slices so Zedd
here was the input to the outer function
which is output of the Emma gadgets so
it kind of lives in this middle layer of
this composed picture so for each such
thing you can consider its slice it's
all the pre image is under the gadget
all x and y that map to it by the
gadgets so in particular compost
function would be constant on each of
the slices so this is an important
notion and here is the the reformulation
that simplest algorithmic reformulation
i can come up with of course we want to
simulate randomized particles but even
simply phrases for determinist protocols
we want to simulate the behavior of it
even a deterministic protocol randomly
averaged over a slice so the claim is
that you fix any deterministic protocol
and I claim that I can come up with a
randomized decision tree that it makes a
number of queries proportional to the
number of bits that the protocol
communicate and outputs a transcript of
the protocol so transcript is just a
concatenation live for the messages that
I said it's the log of the execution so
it's a randomized decision tree so the
output is some distribution of the
transcripts and the claim is that that
output is closed
in the statistical distance to what the
protocol would generate if you fed it a
random input from the slice okay so the
decision tree has query access to Zed
and it needs to produce this behavior of
the protocol on a random input from that
slice so there's no air anywhere this is
really a claim about the gadgets alone
so let me spell out just why this
implies to main theorem we didn't really
do much we just switched our focus maybe
so to prove a main theorem we want to
translate a bounded error protocol into
a bandage error decision tree so here's
my bold pies a randomized protocol and
my decision trees I fix its coins that
the user determines a protocol so I can
apply the simulation which produces a
distribution over transcripts and for
such as prosecute I would just output
the value of the leaf that is reached in
that execution okay I me I did really do
much here there are two random choices
the coins of the protocol and the random
input from the slice do a random choice
i can kind of swap random quantifiers so
nothing's really going on but i just
wanted to give this simple form to focus
our attention okay so one so let's let's
look at what what this goal we're trying
to achieve maybe what what it looks like
pictorially so again our goal we fixed a
deterministic product or this is
communication 101 how do you visualize a
deterministic protocol the communication
matrix is there and maybe maybe Ali's
communicates the first bit on that term
induces some partition of the
communication matrix alone grows those
rows where Alice sends a 0 those roasts
Alice sends a 1 so then Bob speaks that
deduces a refinement of
this partition into rectangles now along
columns so this continues you run the
protocol further and the the
partitioning is refined at every step
until we reach the leaves of the
protocol the leaves are we want to one
correspondence with them with the
rectangles in this final Perdition so so
they okay this this protocol is
deterministic the static partition and
only now I'm injecting randomness this
random point from a slice this is what
we're trying to simulate that the random
voyage from a slice it induces some
distribution over Leafs or equivalently
distribution over walks down the
protocol tree that's the object we're
trying to simulate so maybe I'll just
rewind the rewind back to the very first
message that the protocols how do you
how do we even simulate the very first
message we don't know which slice we're
supposed to be simulating we can only
query bits of this said if needed but
there's a very simple way to at least
get started with the simulation which is
to kind of pretend that Alice's be given
a uniform random input in that would in
this case picture it seems like the
first bit splits the whole communication
matrix in proportions two-thirds
one-third so naive first step in a
simulation is we need to generate this
random walk down protocol tree so we
just choose to go left with probably
two-thirds right with probably one-third
and this is kind of so the kicker here
is we prove them a certain pseudo-random
property of the gadgets that justifies
us doing this and it actually mandates
that this is the only thing you can
these are the only probabilities that
make the simulation work okay so this is
the we call it the uniform marginal
slimmer says that if you have a large
enough rectangle in your communication
matrix a large enough is defined in some
technical manner then this rectangle it
intersects all the slices
at least but moreover if you consider
the take any slice and consider its
intersection with the large rectangle
imagine a uniform distribution there
well then the marginals of that
distribution are close to uniform so
this kind of justifies this our idea is
just if you're still in maintaining a
large rectangle in your simulation then
you just pretend that the marginal
distributions for Alice and Bob are
uniform because really no matter what
the slice is there close to uniform so
at least a few first few bits that are
send either in our simulation or in the
execution corresponding clear slice they
are close to each other look for
something interesting happens when we no
longer have a large rectangle so the
technical condition here is such that
for Bob cept to be large that's a
condition that is always almost surely
going to hold so we're not going to
worry too much about that I mean Bob's
inputs are these very long tables of
strings we can really manage these sets
to have if you think of them as random
variables a huge mean entropy loss but
but Alice holds the short pointers so
it's critical that there's some critical
condition on what it means for alice is
said to be larger we call extends its
this notion of block-wise density from
previous work and so that your condition
says that so bold face X here means the
answer the setting of the uniform
distribution on the set to me is that
it's blocked by stance is to say
consider any subset of these blocks and
2 to the N choices but any brain is
upset you can look at the marginal
distribution on those blocks and we just
require that marginal distribution to
have constant mean entropy rate this
would be the if the maximum imagery
possible but we say ok let's at least
have point 9 of that so this is this
notion of alleys having a dense set and
this is something that can fail and it
fails at some point in the simulation
so this is the part where we actually do
something interesting we start querying
stuff so when when Alice's set loose
density our ideas as to restore it in
the sense that we fix some of Alice's
blocks in order to restore density only
all the other blocks so formally we
compute this density restoring partition
also we used this already in the
previous work where each of the parts in
a partition is such that I've fixed some
blocks in this reality set in order to
make the remaining blocks tells again so
it's like a picture of what's going on
initially all the pointers are very very
random pointing all over the place in
Bob's tables but then you can be this
pretty sure we pick apart in the
partition to branch into with
probability proportional to its size its
kind of again this choice is justified
by the uniform marginals lemma but when
you branch into one of these guys it
happens that we fixed some blocks may be
the first in the second block so the
point just became fixed they're fixing
into the pointing at the fixed places in
imports table and so somehow we have to
make how to query the corresponding
coordinates in this set to figure out
which slice are we simulating and it
typically happens at the place where
pointing to in Bob's table are going to
random enough that no matter what
results we get out of these queries we
can then proceed to restrict Bob set now
into having this point it to base be
consistent with Izzy so this is the
first bit of Z this is the second bit
upset this is basically what the
simulation does if you just ignore these
blocks we fixed and made sure that the
gadget outputs were consistent with Z
then what remains below is again dense
so that means that we can um we can just
continue the simulation pretending that
the marginal so uniform okay so
basically the whole cultural
construction is trying to ensure that
the resulting transcript is close to the
one that would be generated if we had
ran the protocol and random random input
from the slice but then you have to
separately argue that you don't query
too many coordinates which is related to
the size of the subset of blocks we are
fixing okay so that's kind of a sketch
of the simulation and I see I think I
have to have to leave the technicalities
for another time so one let me just
maybe a series with a long day so you
can relax with some some open problems I
I suppose that with this randomized
lifting theorem the next obvious thing
that's open is to try to prove a similar
thing for quantum communication and
greater complexity I should mention this
at a recent paper that for the first
time separated quantum communication
Quebec see from approximately rank or
logarithm of approximate rank
approximate rank being previously our
own only known lower about technique for
this model so that analog of that was
known to hold for query complexity for
quite some time but mean they now
managed to previous for communication do
this if you had had a lifting theorem
for quantum for the girls and of course
the result would follow it so that's one
one motivation may be to look for it
well another direction is that so many
of the listing theorists we have gadgets
the tant third web the resulting quite
ugly functions not really the natural
things we would like we are having
applications like set destroyed pneus so
for those you would like to relate
theorems for constant size gadgets and
that's a another direction which i think
is very important and okay do you like
to mention some challenges which on
necessarily directly related to lifting
theorems but
regular being provocative here like
maybe the most famous conjecturing
communication complexity is this law
ground conjecture that speculate whether
the log of the rank of a boolean matrix
is polynomially related to the
communication complexity of the the
underlying function and again like the
query analog it's known to be true but
we don't know whether the communication
analog is true so I will almost hope
that conjectures falls in that there's
the community is really key somehow
richer than communicate that bit like
we're a complex so that the whole
subject is not just lifting fear from
lifting theorem but okay who knows also
I'm another problem I really like but I
suppose nobody really knows how to
attack it is are these age-old problems
about proving lower bounds for models we
have no explicit lower box for what a
lot of people are truly have been doing
recently is understanding models that
have been already somewhat well
understood but even better but these
models we don't understand at all so
that would be most interesting I
mentioned here one recent work that
pinpoints even even weaker and weaker
models of communication for which we
don't know how to prove it explicit
lower bounds and even formally you can
show that our best methods fail to do so
so you should work on that
yes I think of India thank you property
of the index function it's certainly a
good extractor as is inner product which
we reuse previously I think what the
index catch advisors in just technical
simplicity is that we just need to worry
about Alice's sets being dense so when
that's like what determines what we're
doing and Bob said we don't really worry
about it it's it's allowed to lack a lot
of entropy so like one open problem is
maybe to prove it for the you know
product gadget log n bits in a product
for both players same simulation
algorithm in a product what happens is
like you fix one x then your visit is an
inner product to be this straight so you
good lord there is only divots and you
lost one bit and then you do this
communication a 10 times you cannot
repeat this whereas the drag index in n
which is like
yeah at least unique concept counts this
can work you fix one bit and then
there's maybe in a factor people
anticipate this
yeah one of his legs said something
approximate mashup rise yeah so this is
some paper I think it's due to appear at
stock by Papa Schenker and Rubinstein so
they study some two-player claim where
that the two players need to find an
approximate Nash equilibrium
communicating with each other somehow
and the story with this failure is quite
interesting it they first proved it for
deterministic communica it's hard to
find an approximate nash by a
deterministic lifting theorem and then
we pointed out the lugal actually you
might be able to use these previous
lifting theorems it stood for random we
didn't have the randomized lifting
theorem back then but they did some
additional work got it to work for
randomized communication and now with
with this one you can again simplify the
proof a little bit so the gadget there
will be um I think it's kind of this
complete problem with ppid is this end
of line type of
[Applause]